let's start this morning hearing from
the government a few moments ago I spoke
to the leader of the House of Commons
penny mordant
good morning I'd like to start with the
awful story of Nicola bully who's been
missing now for more than three weeks
both the Home Secretary and the Prime
Minister have expressed concern about
the handling of the investigation I do
share that concern
well I can't imagine what this must have
been like for her family it's bad in our
fifth a member of our family goes goes
missing but to have all this additional
drama and distraction from the most
important thing which is to find out
what has happened to her my thoughts are
are with them I think the Prime Minister
and the Home Secretary have been right
to express concerns about that but but
really the priority here has been what
it always should have been which is to
find her
okay let's talk about the political news
and of course top story today is going
to be Northern Ireland the Prime
Minister says that
we may be close to a deal but we're not
there yet what are the obstacles that
remain to an agreement that would allow
Stormwind to reassemble and possibly
allow you not to have to pursue the
Northern Ireland protocol bill
well look there are encouraging signs
but the Prime Minister has said that
there is still hard work to be done and
everyone will be pulling together to
ensure that we're giving that deal the
best chance possible what matters here
and the prime minister is very focused
on this is what the people of Northern
Ireland think about this deal this has
to be acceptable to all communities in
Northern Ireland and the EU is aware of
that so I I wish them well I think it
would be great if we can arrive at that
point but that's the test it's not what
I or any other member of the commons
thinks it's the people of Northern
Ireland but how close is close is it
days or are we weeks away months what do
you think look I think I think good
progress has been made but clearly there
is still more to be done both both sides
of the negotiations have said we're not
there yet but those negotiations are
still progressing and and there are
there are optimistic signs all right
well look um
people can be helpful and they can be
that's helpful and let's talk about the
various parties to this summon your own
parties say that the European court of
justice should play no part for example
in settling disputes uh between Britain
and the EU on trade
um can you envisage any agreement in
which the ecj plays no part at all
being acceptable to the EU look I'm not
party to the negotiations I'm not cited
on the detail but what I can tell you is
that unless this deal is satisfactory to
to all communities in Northern Ireland
it won't be possible it's not going to
work but it's also going to be
satisfactory to the EU hasn't it it has
but the I mean the dups tests that they
have referred to are not a random wish
list they are promises that we have made
to the to the people of Northern Ireland
that that is the the bar that this deal
has to has to get over and uh and I know
that the prime minister is completely
focused on that
you're in danger of being a bit clear
here which is unusual the dp7 tests
involve no role for the ecj are you
saying that this can't happen
unless that test is met the prime
minister is focused on removing those
practical difficulties but he has also
been talking about the the Democratic
deficit he's been talking about ensuring
that the people of Northern Ireland
through their representatives are able
to have a say on any future regulation
that they might be subject to these are
important things it is very tough it's
tough stuff but that is what the prime
minister is focused on I've no further
detail on the on the nitty-gritty of the
of the negotiations Trevor but I I think
there are encouraging signs but there is
a lot more to be done absence of detail
doesn't seem to have discourage
um some of your colleagues from having a
view including the former prime minister
who says or rather a source close to Mr
Johnson uh saying this morning that
it would be a great mistake to drop the
Northern Ireland protocol Bill the story
behind this is that apparently he thinks
that it's absolutely essential to make
sure that you have leverage that you
retain the ability to withdraw
unilaterally from
um the the protocol
do you think it is possible to reach an
agreement that would satisfy that part
of your party
but look I think the the first thing to
say is and I think the Prime Minister
would acknowledge this we're only able
to be having these negotiations and
discussions because of what previous
administrations have done and the
command paper and the the Northern
Ireland protocol Bill have been helpful
to get us where we are today I think
that's that's the first thing and uh the
intervention by a source close to the
the previous prime minister is helpful
to remind uh the EU of that of that bill
and uh what this deal actually has to
deliver but I'll come back to it Trevor
it's not about me or any other Member of
Parliament it is about the communities
in Northern Ireland and getting this to
work for them that is our priority I
know it's your job to be diplomatic but
seriously you think that Boris Johnson's
intervention is helpful I think that all
parties want this to be a success they
want those very practical issues that
the people of Northern Ireland have been
grappling with and that are causing
unnecessary friction in our trading
Arrangements they they want the the
territorial Integrity of the United
Kingdom to be a certainty this is what
we all want
it's difficult but we are making
progress and uh and I wish the Prime
Minister well but
forgive me I I understand what you're
trying to say that there needs to be a
consensus everybody needs to be generous
and so on but it's already clear that
for some members of your party and I'm
going to come to the dup in a moment
there are red lines uh John Redwood who
senior member of the party he represents
a particular strain of opinion has
tweeted this morning words to the effect
that the EU consultation with the
Northern Ireland assembly would still
leave Northern Ireland under EU control
these people are not going to come
quietly are they they're not going to be
as generous as you apparently are being
this morning
well it's again it's not about a winning
a vote in the in the Commons we we don't
know what the following procedures will
will need to be it all depends on what
that uh what that deal is and if we if
we get to a deal at all but uh I I think
everyone is uh is agreeing with each
other unless we have every community in
Northern Ireland behind this deal it
won't last and it won't work that this
is why this is difficult
um but I think you know it's it's at
moments like this when when governments
and prime ministers are tested and the
prime minister is been absolutely clear
that the priority in this is the people
of Northern Ireland that that is what he
has in his mind uh and what his team
have in their minds when they're
negotiating all right well I'll give
this one last go what is Boris Johnson
actually up to
well Boris is is being Boris but I
wouldn't say this is this is a
completely unhelpful uh intervention
um and I think as I say the Prime
Minister I think will acknowledge that
uh having the Northern Ireland protocol
Bill there having the the work uh that
the former prime minister did is has
helped us get where we are but it's
always been our preference to try and
have a negotiated settlement and and
that is what everyone is working to
there's still a lot to be done or
progress has been made all right let me
take you a word about the Northern
Ireland communities the Democratic units
party
has been pretty clear
I've put some of the points that they
share with members of your party to you
already
um
and come into the line
um Stormont is not going to reassemble
uh is the government ready to for
example resume direct rule if the
assembly simply just can't sit because
the dup won't accept a deal
so look we we have and we've we've done
this previously we we've had to step in
we we obviously want to make sure that
there's a there's a budget there we we
are the backstop for uh for for the
assembly that's that's always been the
case but but we want uh we want
government to be to be re-established in
in Northern Ireland that is that is what
we we want and uh
but you haven't been able to do it and
that's not necessarily your fault if if
Mr Donaldson and his colleagues to
Jeffrey I beg your pardon Donaldson and
his colleagues say we're not going to
play ball are you ready to resume direct
rule look there is there is obviously an
element of of local politics and all of
this but but fundamentally the the deal
that the prime minister is trying to uh
negotiate at the moment is is going to
be a key part of getting the assembly
stood up again that is why it is
absolutely critical that all parties
have confidence in the process and have
confidence with what is arrived at we we
don't know whether we're going to be
able to secure a deal or not but if we
do um and it's a good one then that will
play a big part in uh in getting the
assembly re-established
you're obviously very hopeful and um the
late party says that um
actually they will support
a deal if it's one that for example
maintains uh the Integrity of the Good
Friday agreement
um
are you okay about that but you might
actually have to if you have to
introduce legislation and it possibly
might not do but if you do have to
introduce legislation are you happy to
get that legislation through on the back
of uh labor votes against some
conservative opposition and the up
opposition well look this is a hype
hypothetical situation about about
having a vote we don't we don't know
what a deal is going to look like and
whether whether we will need to to do
that or not I would hope if we arrive at
a good deal that everyone would be
supporting it but I I come back to the
point Trevor and I I'm sorry to repeat
it but it is a pretty fundamental one it
doesn't really matter what any of us in
the House of Commons think about this
the deal has to satisfy the people of
Northern Ireland okay all right
um
elsewhere Mr mclinch says that they're
going to stop the trains again the RCN
first time in its history it's going out
on 48 hour strike without cover Junior
doctors yesterday to say they're likely
to come out
um is it the ministers is it Minister
Minister's position still that there's
not much you can do to stop this chaos
look I think it is
political cynicism of the worst kind to
encourage strikes the only people that
benefit from strikes are the labor party
striking workers don't benefit from
strikes and I think it's lunacy to
say to people the best way to help make
ends meet is to drive those ends further
apart these these are not helpful we
need to focus on issues that that each
sector is facing those are what the
respective secretaries of state are are
doing but but strikes are not helpful
and I would encourage people not to not
to do that well I can't speak for Mr
Lynch or Ms Cullen or the BMA but I
suspect if they were here they'd say
they're not much they're not very
helpful to you but they might be helpful
to these striking workers and let's say
let me ask you again
it's going to happen
is the government's view still that it
cannot play a role in avoiding these
strikes strikes are not helpful to
striking words no but that's not the
question I'm asking you as well asking
you what the government can understand
what you said because it's important
striking workers lose pay out of their
pay packets when they're on strike if
their Union demands are met with an
inflationary pay rise they lose because
that equates to about a thousand pounds
extra in tax per household and you you
it doesn't help on on the issue that
everyone is facing on inflation strikes
do not help striking workers strikes
only help the labor party and it's the
same attitude Trevor that
miners now on strike at the start of the
warmest summer on record it's the it's
the same old dogma and situation the
only thing that is going to enable us to
make progress on on the genuine issues
that certain sectors are facing is is
discussions discussions around stresses
on the NHS and all of them that is what
secretary you can tell them that there's
not helpful to them until you're blue in
the face but from their point of view if
they get a pay right that is going to be
helpful surely I mean that's what that's
what they're there for not if it embeds
inflation uh no um they they are it's
it's I'm I'm sorry but it's a it's a
myth that strikes are helpful they're
not they they exacerbate uh financial
problems for the very people going out
on strike and they also are going to
have a knock-on effect on canceled
appointments on missed education uh it's
it's not good for the country and I'd
encourage people not to do it yeah but
they but they're going to get poorer
anyway because inflation hasn't been
conquered as Mr Hunt never tires of
telling us so they're getting poorer
year by year anyway let me put it to you
again is the government simply going to
say sit on his hands and say
look chaps you're not helping anybody
you're you know it's a little fit school
teacher issue or you're wasting your own
time here I mean honestly can ministers
do nothing no the ministers are doing a
lot the the you will know that the prime
minister's priorities three of them are
on are focused on the economy including
halving uh in inflation uh that should
be our Focus that is what is going to
benefit those individuals it will
benefit also uh the the rest of the
country as well so we're very focused on
this but uh make no mistake the strikes
are not helping all right look um Mr
sunak said yesterday he wants everybody
to double down to support Ukraine
um we're not sending fighter fighter
jets despite the um clear the appeal
that Mrs zielinsky
made to us are we just to be clear we're
not going to send them quite a joke look
we've not ruled out uh particular things
and indeed the Prime Minister has asked
the defense secretary to look at a raft
of things including uh aircraft and we
are obviously providing training support
um but the defense secretary is also
he's very focused on what is going to
help long term but also in the immediate
future and the prime minister's speech
at the security Summit in Munich was
really a a call to other nations to
recognize the critical period we are in
now in terms of Ukraine securing that
Victory that's interesting there was a
world in which penny more than might
have been the defense secretary would
the penny would penny more than his
defense secretary have wanted to send
fighter jet if we had any to spare I'm
I'm completely in step with Ben Wallace
Ben Wallace I think has been a fantastic
defense secretary he is very focused on
giving Ukraine the support that it needs
we have led Europe in providing that
support and we're doing a huge amount
and we will continue to do that what we
have also said is we are going to step
that up in the next few months we're
going to be sending more than we did
in the entire
period of last year and and that is
because we have to bring this this war
to an end we have to help Ukraine secure
that victory that is in everyone's
interest and this is a really critical
period for them to do that there are
limits to what we can do surely
um there's a former Chief of uh actually
the chief of army General
um Sir Richard Barons who says today we
need another three billion pounds we
hear that the a year to keep our status
as a leading European military power we
hear that the defense secretary wants
another 10 billion a year we understand
that our own Munitions stocks are
being depleted because we're helping the
ukrainians
are we going to do whatever it takes
whatever it does to our own military
capacity
we know this is our first job as a
government and our record in government
has been that we have prioritized uh
defense and we have kept defense
spending strong always met our NATO
commitments but for those worried about
this I would say listen to what the
Prime Minister said in Munich listen to
what the government said in the Autumn
statement last year which recognized the
need to increase defense spending look
at what the chancellor has previously
said the son of an admiral one of the
most experienced people in cabinet about
his desire to increase defense spending
to three percent as he has made a
commitment in previous years and look at
Ben Wallace who no one can doubt his
commitment to our Armed Forces I am
confident we will keep defense spending
strong and it will be the priority for
this government okay I'm only hiring you
along because of course the big
development biggest pure political
development has been the decision of the
Scottish first minister to stand down
um
no nobody really knows the full truth
why she's made that decision but one
element surely must have been the
decision of the Scottish secretary
Alistair Jack to block Hollywood
legislation on gender recognition
given what you yourself have said on
this issue
do you really think that Aleister Jack
was correct to do that did you support
that decision yes he was because this is
a matter not so much about the the
rights or wrongs or the merits of of
what Scotland was was trying to to do
for Trans people it was about the impact
it was having on the rest of the UK
there have been many many positive
things about Devolution but it has torn
at the social fabric of the United
Kingdom and the impact of what Scotland
was was doing on the on the workings as
you will well know of the equalities Act
was a serious problem
Scotland knew about this but everything
that you have said recently in
the past including period when you
yourself were Minister for equalities
suggests that you would have supported
the Scottish legislation no is that true
no on the issue itself I wouldn't have
because I did not wish for uh this to be
split out from Healthcare I think this
this was a very important thing that it
remained in healthcare but what we think
about the merits of what Scotland were
trying to do is not the issue here the
reason why Alistair Jack has done what
he has done is because what Scotland was
trying to do was going to have an impact
on the workings of the equalities act
across the whole of the UK pretty modern
thank you very much thank you